Détachez-moi dans les secondes.
parler. Le véhicule est à moi.
-moi dans les secondes.
- L'homme dans cette vidéo est
Brice Dossa, arrivé au Québec
Jeudi après-midi au Marché
Central, il est interpellé
par des policiers, qui
le soupçonnent d'une tentatitur.
- C'est parce que je suis noir?
- L'homme est aussitôt menotté,
les policiers poursuivent
BRICE DOSSA
victime d'erreur p
- Ils m'ont demandé mon nom,
j'ai dit mon nom, ils ont dit :
Monsieur?"
- Il s'agissait en fait de son
propre véhicule. Malgré tout,
plusieurs minutes.
- J'ai dit : "Mais
je suis encore dans les menottes
si c'est ma voiture."
le libérer, mais constatent
qu'ils n'ont pas la clé de leurs
propres menottes.
humilié. Là, ils ont fait appel
aux policiers, à leurs
collègues, qui sont venus après
une quinzaine de minutes.
général Sûreté du Québec
- Je vous dirais qu'il y a
certainement un manquement.
- Marcel
à comprendre pourquoi
les policiers n'avaient
de clés en leur possession.
- L'individu est menotté trop
- Diffusée sur les médiassociauo
de l'arrestation a déclenché
une temp... estime le responsaba
sécurité publique de Montréa
... estionsable de la
sécurité publique de Montréal.
Le ministre François Bonnardel
vérifications qui s'imposent
auprès du SPVM.
- C'est un profilage racial,
à ma personne.
- À la lumièreuté solidauté sole
Andrés Fontecilla demande
à Québec de ne pas porter
en appel la récente décision
les interceptions sans motif.
ANDRÉS FONTECIL
Québec solidaire, Laurier-Dorion
- S'il a été intercepté en verta
sécurité routière, il y a motif
de croire qu'il y avait
là du profilage racial.
à fermer l'oeil depuis
son arrestation.
- Même- S'il a procédé au dépôt
d'une plainte en déontologie
policière, il n'écarte pas de
se tourner vers les tribunaux.
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
de journée, la Fraternité
des policiers a réagi.
HADI HASSIN
depuis la diffusion de cette
vidéo, il y a plus
qui ont réagi par l'entremise
des médias sociaux, notamment,d,
Dominique Anglade sur son comptt
à la Fraternité des policiers
de rester prudents,
et voici ce qu'on
qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qu'est-ce q,
le désengagement policier?
C'est lorsque des s intervenir
parce qu'ils en craignent
les répercussions
sur leur travail,
Je rappelle en terminant
police
de Montréal mène actuellement
une enquête sur cette affaire.